the charade is being exposed people in
positions of power and influence they've
been changing definitions all trying to
cover up past mistakes that they've made
we're now humans American citizens are
suffering well the largest media
platform in the world The Joe Rogan
Experience recently called them out and
exposed all the nonsense here's what Joe
had to say about officials trying to
change the definition of a recession
people would think that it's trivial
because they are talking about this
economic downturn but it's not trivial
because we've always used that term
recession and we've always used that
term to define whether or not the
economic policies that are currently in
place and whether or not the management
the government has done a good job of
making sure that the economy stays in a
good place that's they definitely
haven't done that so in order to escape
that in you know that sort of
Distinction they're literally changing
the definition which is terrible and it
should be pushed back against in a big
way it should it should be something
that people get angry about like hey
you're [__] with definitions in order
to pretend that you're doing a good job
now this is a big deal because Joe Rogan
gets more than 11 million listeners and
viewers on every single episode that is
multiples higher than any other
mainstream Outlet in the world Joe's got
a unique way of delivering insights and
opinions that resonates with the average
American citizen and those people around
the world the second that he starts to
talk about hey this is nonsense you
can't change definitions and by the way
you should be called out and there
should be pushback against this nonsense
it's over all of a sudden the officials
they're being exposed because they ended
up making mistakes they made bad
decisions and now you can't simply try
to change the definition of certain
words to make it seem like you didn't
screw up ultimately we are in an
economic contraction the Federal Reserve
is creating tighter Financial conditions
and yes we are are in a recession
regardless of what they try to Gaslight
us about
Joe Rogan's calling it out and so are
many many more the tide has shifted the
internet is undefeated and the officials
can say whatever they want
but the people on the street the people
who have to go to work every day and buy
everyday Goods they know that the
situation is worse today than it was
just six months ago hey you did you like
this video great we make five of them a
day and post them here on this channel
make sure you subscribe like the video
and see you next time